g reçoit maintenant le comédien michel
galabru pour monsieur amédée au théâtre
comédia michel galabru bonsoir on serait
alors concernant la télévision vous avez
dit je fait l'idiot ce n'est pas mon
honneur c'est une espèce de service
après-vente pénible on essaie de sauter
sur le mode rôle alors vous vivez ça un
petit peu comme des expériences
négatives quand vous venez parler de
votre travail à la télévision
non mais qui m'avait intéressé c'est que
j'avais vu aux états unis des comédiens
comme comme moi je sais pas des grandes
stars s'étaient c'était obligé de faire
ce service puisque je veux parler de la
pièce et la télévision est infâme
formidable agents de de propagande
je les voyais et raconter leur histoire
partir la maison leur appréhension leur
traque leur pudeur et la difficulté de
jeux présentés on est toujours quand
même un peu intimidés ils avaient les
mêmes problèmes que nous savez les
passionnés oui sentez vous à l'aise ne
soyez oui on vous aime et on est heureux
de vous voir en tous les cas les japs
alors la pièce en question c'est
monsieur amédée qu'un formidable succès
de si j'étais jouer repris plusieurs
fois dont une pièce d'alain reynaud
fourton mise en scène de jean-pierre
dravel avec bernadette lafont et c'est
quand j le théâtre comédia je dis à nos
amis téléspectateurs c'est ce qu'on
appelait nous l'eldorado eldorado
boulevard de 4 boulevard de strasbourg
alors l'histoire c'est simple c'est
amédée un prof de français vous prof de
français à la retraite qui rencontre une
prostituée qui se retrouvent patron de
bordel voilà le pitch comme on dit si le
l'argument comme on disait avant est
très simple et c'est un prix mais j'ai
une très bonne situation parce que le
comique au fond c'est le type qui est
placé voulu malgré lui dans une
situation ce professeur qui est un type
très très jeune est très quotidien très
français moyen est brusquement projeté
dans un milieu qu'il ne connaît pas et
devient macro sea le cellule le
contraire de ce qu'il est alors ça ça
ressort comme effectivement très très
puissant et c'est vrai les gens moi j'ai
vu la pièce les gens rient toutes les 30
secondes c'est incroyable et d'ailleurs
quand vous étiez en tournée pour l'école
des femmes
les gens venaient vous demandez mais
quand est-ce que vous reprend
monsieur amédée c'est quand même
extraordinaire de jouer avec la cia aux
caciques et les gens vous dire ce qu'ils
avaient bien rigolé puis que bon le
classique ça n'intéresse pas tout le
monde est là c'est quelquefois alors
tout à l'heure je vous ai vues croisées
philippe tesson je sais pas que s'il a
fait une critique de la pièce en
question mais vous dites et je parle pas
du tout de philippe en disant ça mais
vous dites le public parisien est
devenue moche c'est à dire que il est
engloutie dans une espèce de snobisme un
peu intello est ce que cette pièce a
souffert de ça ou être au contraire les
gens ils vont sans se préoccuper de la
critique et c'est plein tous les soirs
ah non non non je crois que c'est top ça
s'adresse à un public très populaire le
très simple populaire et puis il ya une
certaine catégorie public qui de noeuds
qui ne vient pas des gendarmes
enfin bon pas par contre quelques fois
on a des visites inattendues qui se
disent je me suis amusé au mythique donc
envoyer tes sens henné reçoit le ca
marche très bien vous en foutez michel
alors le seul au but le seul problème
c'est la mémoire les 200 lignes vous
vous dites je me lève la nuit et je me
dis merde qu'est ce que je dois dire
après votre femme elle gueule un peu
vous avez des preuves de mémoire non
mais ça c'est le problème du comédien
sait on n'a pas de problèmes de mémoire
on a les problèmes de la psychose de 2
du trou de mémoire et l'enjoint dit j'ai
dix mille lignes pourquoi je vais me
souviendrai de l'ami du 1e mai quand on
songe que quand on présente quelques
fois deux personnes qui ont collé très
bien puisque c'est le trou de mémoire
on se rappelle pas moi j'admire ce sera
capable de david a échoué
alors on a cette hantise mais c'est une
psychose
il ya une grecque de damer ratings qui
vit la peur paralyse à mémoire l'époque
je prenais ça mais vous ça remonte à vos
débuts à la comédie française et le
monde divers êtes obligés d'apprendre
700 lignes en six jours et ça a été pour
vous brille plus sur cinq ou six
chansons
oui oui à 4 aussi hélas 3 qu'est ce que
vous faites dans ces cas là bas ce que
vous dites on va consulter le texte en
coulisses derrière il ya un comédien qui
vous rend service qui vous laissent
partir qu'est ce qui se passe quand on a
un trou de mémoire rapidement maintenant
ça devient un peu embêtant parce qu'ils
ont supprimé les souffleurs il occupait
bien soin pourquoi alors par des raisons
économiques je ne sais pas quoi et c'est
une erreur parce que le souffle avoue
rassuré par sa présence elle
on savait que si jamais il y avait un
pépin qui peut toujours survenir
l'instant et qui survient et bien vous
pouvez vous avancer doucement et il ya
ces espèces de petits trous là où on
voit une figure bien qu'ils aient si
vous êtes c'est ça ne fait pas ça à
regarder ça c'est génial ça puisque ça
vous allez ça dans l'oreille et si vous
avez un trou de mémoire il ya quelqu'un
qui vous souffle le nom wii jeu mais
j'ai utilisé avant j'étais c'est génial
c'est génial mais attention il faut
s'habituer
il ya un métier de sa wii ça fait pas
attention pas un jour vous dit quelqu'un
m'avait dit mais si tu as peur tu te
fais sable et ben non narration hong hao
panique
il faudra voir une grande habitude mais
alors je me suis intéressé à votre vie
pour savoir un peu commenté interviews
portraits savoir comment vous étiez
devenu michel galabru alors votre père
était directeur du port de safi au maroc
et vous avez une enfance plutôt heureuse
les premières années de votre vie vous
étiez là bas vous n'allez pas trop à
l'école il y avait un grand noir ce qui
fait de vous qui s'appelait mahdjoub et
vous avez une vie plutôt plutôt sympa
votre père était été dur avec vous c'est
ça qui vous a peut-être laissé ce trac
cette espèce de toujours et peut-être
des étés chrome et et d'autres fois les
parents la plupart dhr certaine
bourgeoisie j'étais gentil s'était des
braves gens mais ils étaient sévères
existerait les couleurs et vous savez
autrefois les classes étaient très
séparés il y avait la classe ouvrière et
réclamer du pain alors maintenant le
pain le gaspille on en mange pas et puis
la classe bourgeoise moyenne et puis
alors il y avait de la classe riche
ouais et quand on était dans la classe
bourgeoise les parents est toujours peur
que d'une déchéance à dire que c'est
travailler de tes mains c'est un ouvrier
monfils maintenant conscience a
maintenant ça existe une vraie en moins
parce que quand vous avez un plombier
qui vous prend 1000 francs pour y
réparer de chasse d'eau et que vous avez
un docteur qui vous prend 150 francs
ouais bon c'est plus la même chose
non mais c'est vrai que votre père mais
pas vous soyez comédien et quand vous
avez fait le
matamore révision comique il a eu un
malaise social me voyant dans le costume
de matériel alors après vous allez voir
vous quittez le maroc sur le père dirige
est donc apparemment des ports vous avez
vos arbres et là alors vous première
déception l'école j'étais viré cette
fois est la première référence à guitry
quai pour vous quelqu'un d'extrêmement
important vous dit c'est pas grave moi
j'étais viré cette fois guitry été
violée 12 fois en importance de guitry
pour vous c'est c'est colossal puisque
vous étiez petit voulu d'abord être
footballeur lui est michèle seiler et
puis après chauffeur de car et puis
après vous dit j'étais sacha guitry
oui je n'ai jamais été moi-même
d'allaoui ça continue un peu je ne
m'aime pas tellement oui parce que c'est
normal je suis enfoncé dans le quotidien
dans ma personne qui par la
fréquentation que j'aurais est courante
et banale le m'intéresse m'a dit aussi
que vous avez un physique qui ressemble
pas à votre mental en fait non je suis
un dur et donc c'est vrai que vous
habitez un corps différent de voilà
voilà
alors vous êtes tellement ressembler à
guitry que vous étiez des bagues pour
faire comme lui enfin bon votre premier
nom de théâtre c'était michel livry vous
portiez les mêmes costumes d'étudier les
mêmes pentes et même écrivain est alors
le goût du théâtre vous est venue à
montpellier quand une de vos tentes vous
a fait écouter un disque de guitry et
yvonne printemps a été le l'amour masqué
et puis de bureau narry de bureaux et
les parcs des pirates des trucs comme ça
parce que j'entendais ça tout le temps
oui et je continue à les écouter afin
que rue les écouter guitry oui alors
après vous avez le bac vous a quand même
essayé cinq fois avant de l'avoir et la
boue votre père vous fassiez du toit
mais vous monter à paris votre père et
vous avez dit un truc terrible vous avez
dit je veux que tu travailles au
contentieux chez schneider et j'imagine
ce que ça a dû vous faire
or je le savais pas ce que ça voulait
dire et ça m'a paru il a été maladroit
parce qu'ils ne pourraient pas trouver
un terme plus rébarbatifs c'était les
contentieux de cessna vers moi j'aurais
échoué complètement oui c'est déjà
c'était le creusot ouais c dr c'est le
thé le baron empain qui après la
suppression des grands mères et pères
parce que je n'ai les rêves ancenay
ronde et bien sûr alors après vous
partez à paris alors là une espèce de
caen vous quitter l'endroit où vous
habitez votre frère fait la quête vous
vendez votre fono votre collection de
timbres monter à paris votre mère pleure
votre père
pas content il lève la galerie comme ça
il n'est pas très content et vous
arrivez à paris donc c'est un peu
rastignac donc un jeu la vie à ce moment
là je vais à 24 secondes tout comme sa
23e fait trois ans au début c'est pas
drôle vous êtes contrôleurs au tnp et
puis un jour il ya ces gens pignol
devant l'église de la madeleine qui
commençait cette révélation de il vous a
dit vous êtes comique et vous avez dit
dans ma famille c'est vrai les gens sont
drôles comment ça s'est passé
oui oui c'est bénéfique ça c'est le
petit déclic
il m'a dit c'est curieux c'est devant
l'église à bagdad mossoul et dans un
court le cours de jean s était le lady
day c'était un personnage doyen général
français c'était un grand bonhomme raté
je suis très reconnaissant et pignol
était un ami intime qu'il avait connu à
montpellier c'est moi qui lui a donné le
goût du théâtre il après il a apprêté
réalisateur à la télévision mais cela et
nous étions dans qu'élèves et il m'a dit
c'est curieux quand même parce que ta
famille et drôle ton père est drôle moi
je trouvais pas mon père par aman
j'avais plutôt peur et il m'a dit eh toi
c'est curieux pourquoi tu es plus drôle
dans la vie et puis sur scène tu devrais
chercher quand il a eu raison de me
faire chercher dans des racines communes
dans l'origine et j'écoutais mon père
parlait hier voilà pour la première fois
j'ai entendu des choses des bruits avoir
de drôles donc rôle dans l'intonation
alors après trois ans de conservatoire a
quand même là vous qui avez toujours
tout raté enfin cinq fois le bac virait
de cette école où les premiers prix
classique et comédie classique comédie
moderne au conservatoire et en 1950 vous
entré à la comédie française avec robert
hier ce que je salue parce que c'est
qu'ils regardent l'émission et c'est
quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup ici c'est
un génie ouais c'est ingénieux et j'ai
joué à côté de lui les faux brute de
scapin et ça a été quelque chose de
absolument extraordinaire oui je le
salue aussi par pudeur on ne se voit pas
où on en a pas souvent mais moi j'ai et
qu'ils le sachent j'ai toujours et
beaucoup aimé et admiré d'y admirer lui
a dit il est venu dans cette émission
fait très peu de télé
si l'année dernière on lui a pu lui dire
à quel point ils avaient été importants
pour louis basse crible le pot il a été
n a pas été très justes avec lui c'était
un des plus grands acteurs de notre
temps et et robert hirsch de gens passer
si les pages et juin alors bon votre
père aussi toujours lui un quand vous
êtes à la comédie-française il va voir
le l'administrateur comme il allait voir
le proviseur quand il va voir ça
pourquoi doit pouvoir recommander le
petit truc alors voilà ça c'est en cinq
ans que vous rentrez comédie française
est restée jusqu'à 57 d'ailleurs en 50
et en fait votre premier film qui
s'appelle ma femme ma vache et moi je
vous avoue je connais pas le fils de jan
de weghe et 20 ans plus tard donc nous
aura fallu vingt ans vingt ans plus tard
je dis ça parce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans les villes et carrière
cette espèce d'abnégation et de
d'entêtement qu'il faut c'est à dire que
j'ai mis 20 entre 51 71 ans 71 vous
faites le viager et tchernia qui le
premier film finalement ou là on dit
attends galabru s'est pas seulement à un
comique comme ça et tout s'éteint c'est
un grand acteur et alors après vous avez
fait section spéciale costa gavras le
juge et l'assassin de taverny tout le
monde connaît avec noiret et puis
parallèlement la série des gendarmes
c'est dire que vous êtes toujours est
passé d'un d'un genre à l'autre non mais
c'est à dire que j'ai fait les gendarmes
avant oui
pour résumer tout ce que vous dites il
ya un critique dans le jura lui dis moi
je crois que c'est pierre billard donc
un critique épidémie non il a mis et de
me rappelle de cette critique qui la vie
le génie de taviani et d'avoir trouvé
dans le ringard du gendarme
ouais sont là ça bah oui voilà ça c'est
fait observer que ça résume un peu
l'état d'esprit c'est vrai que des gens
du cinéma
alors vous avez fait 200 films alors on
vous dit toujours que deux interviews la
télé vous avez fait des navets bas vous
dites oui évidemment j'ai vu évidemment
parce que j'avais des pensions
alimentaires à payer j'avais des impôts
comme tout le monde qu'il ya des femmes
aussi non si madjid
oui en fait tout ce qu'ils écoutent
j'avais écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
gelé perdu au 18 mai et comment on fait
si votre virginité dont vous parlez est
la fille s'appelait muna c'est
extraordinaire parce que vous avez pris
une prostituée qui avait une montre pour
être sûr de rentrer à paris
les cours de maths extraordinaire c'est
que
j'ai retrouvé le fils de cette percée
assez fou d'ailleurs des cours ouais un
garçon charmant qui fait du théâtre fils
de mouna mais il est pas il est pas mona
il est pas il n'est pas professionnel
il fait du théâtre amateur à montpellier
on me l'a présenté récemment panier
maintenant alors quand elle vous dit va
faire ta petite toilette venez vous
laver les pieds et ça extraordinaire
et oui parce que ma mère budgétaire par
exemple mais c'est marrant de vous voir
là vous êtes plutôt souriant plutôt de
bonne humeur et pourtant souvent vous
êtes un peu dépressif un peu parce que
vous êtes très lucide c'est pour ça
ouais je m'efforce à la lucidité et à
l'objectivité ce qui est par koba
d'avoir tous n'arrivent jamais
d'ailleurs on y parvient jamais mais moi
je suis si peu timide je veux passer
d'un centime à le faire aujourd'hui la
de fleury complète à l'abattement de
temps ça dure c'est très bien mais en
plus vous souffrez pas de votre âge
puisque dit je me sens jeune dans une
vieille voiture mais vous dis je me sens
jeanne où vous avez page pas que vous
avez on peut le dire non on ne peut pas
se dire d'accord n'agira pas alors je
dis pas ça ne ce n'est pas de se
préciser
on a l'âge de sa mort serait dire que
tant jeu bourré pour dire il était vieux
pas avant est-ce que dernière question
est-ce que vous des fois vos angoisses
ne viennent pas du fait que finalement
vous ne croyez pas vous ne croyez pas
que vous dites
s'il existe c'est pas un brave homme
c'est pas très gentil pour lui et oui
mais c'est pas gentil pour nous parce
que quelqu'un qui dit avoir bon c'est
peut-être un peu puéril ce que je dis et
primaire enfin on n'a pas de réponse
dans les dates ou créer c'est tout il
voit tout il a tout créé tout tout tout
tout les sentiments il est regardé dans
la merde et qu'elle nous savons avec des
maladies effrayante imaginé cette petite
boule qui est la terre qu'il a infesté
de microbes qu'elle de cécité quelle
nécessité s'il était tout puissant de
faire ça voudrait une réponse et comme
disait sacha guitry abba est ce que vous
croyez
il est le moindre signe serait le
bienvenu à la balance est formidable en
fait ma chute c'est ce que cela ait le
moindre signe formidable très loin c'est
bien quand termine sur guitry l'ajout
remercie beaucoup pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou